بمرور الوقت اتضح ان الجبهه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا عباره عن اتحاد مجموعه من الجيوش
تتقاسم الميدان على النصر من انتقاد
الجنرالات الى قائد الاركان مباشره
بريكوجين
اتهموب بمحاوله القضاء على باجنر رغم انها
تحارب في الصفوف الاماميه في معركه بخموت
الوحشيه
نشرت صورا لخسائرها البشريه خلال يوم واحد
والسبب لا يعود لاسلوب الدفع بالامواج
البشريه الذي تتبناه باج الى ازمه ذخيره
ناجمه عن خيانه غرازمون
نشر وثائق تثبت ان فاجنر اللم تستلم الا
50% من شحنات الذخيره داعيا الروس بالضغط
على وزاره الدفاع انقاضا لارواح مقاتلي
النداء اسمر الامدادات في الطريق
اختار الموعد بعنايه في ذكرى الحرب الاولى
الكرملين بحاجه لنصر معنوي لكنه ذكر وزاره
الدفاع
عن تحقيق الاهداف وهو ما ترك المجال
لميلاد
عسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا عام حافل شهدت
من خلاله موسكو اولا عمليه تعبئه جزئيه
للقوات قامت من خلالها بتجديد اكثر من 300
الف جنديا روسي بالاضافه الى المتطوعين
كما شهدت تغييرا متكررا للقاده العسكريين
للعمليه العسكريه ثالثا زياده التعداد
القوات المسلحه الروسيه الذي سيرتفع الى
مليون ونصف المليون فردا في الفتره من
2023 الى 2026 واخيرا الاتهامات التي
وجهها قائد مجموعه فاغنر الخاصه الى وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
بتعمد حرمان قواته من الذخيره الكافيه
والتي بدورها نفت صحتها لكن على الرغم من
كل ذلك ووفقا لمركز ابحاث الراي العام
لعموم روسيا زاد مستوى ثقه الروس بالرئيس
بوتين الى
بالمئه والذي برره الكرملين بان اللحظه
الحاسمه التي تمر بها موسكو دفعت المجتمع
الى التضامن حول الرئيس